Anderson trying to go up a number the
one two three and knocks it in put the
tough way tangled up and see that's
nothing that's that's not a big deal
right now there's no crossover right
there it was a nice step back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we want to see a dribble move watch this
one double behind your back
knock it down and the bench is loving it
coming at Chris Paul takes it out under
the basket and suddenly goes two times
behind his back do we fall on the ground
and then finishes it off 1 2 Paul goes
down curry knocks down the jump shot
this guy is something special
down there it's a challenger sir and
sting it off that rim but you are just
leave here tonight I don't feel right
watching this I don't feel right watch
him in and enjoying this that is
inhumane thank you mister
[Applause]
he put him on the deck and then he
hesitated
let's take a look now me to have this
bad dal-gu Johnson
too much sauce
Stan with his team and with three tend
to go in the fourth met for the lead and
ha
[Applause]
a ball handling wizard at the Angelo
Russell know we had a frog understands
he losses man on a few stations on the
local news tonight you don't have to
take a team man out of the same time you
might as well this is on everybody
Brooke Jesus idiom that they end off now
the shot-blocking to the best banjo
[Applause]
playing Dancing with the Stars with
Stephen Adams and down goes Adams does
it all for me the glue guy for Golden
State in straight lines 11 points
against seven assists
that's ridiculous
he has taken over this last 35 games or
so just the double cross he's making
things that are so difficult look easy
there's your crossover draymond falls
down a double cross Omega and then a
one-hand scoop shot at the rim